joining the show right now nine-time pro
bowler six-time all-pro but more
importantly football hall-of-famer it's
got a nice ring to it allen fanuca joins
the show how are you alan how's it feel
to be forever immortalized in canton
ohio
words can't describe it it's great
is it like after my wedding where my
face just hurt for a week from smiling
what's the come down like from a weekend
in canton ohio
um
you know it's definitely you know it's a
little quiet it's quiet at the house you
know it's definitely a a non-stop face
up there but it's uh it's it's been
great you know with
sitting around kicking around the
stories and things that we we didn't
even my wife and i didn't even have a
chance to discuss or talk about just
because we were so busy so it's been
great catching up it was great to see
all the steelers towels out there too to
see the steelers faithful to see
steelers nation representing what was it
like to be a part of the festivities as
a member of the pittsburgh steelers
family
oh man it was so great you know i kept
telling guys that it was pittsburgh west
for the weekend
and uh it was just great man the the
steeler fans are so tremendous and they
came out there and it showed their
support for for all of us and uh you
know forever grateful and thankful that
they they they do what they do and that
they can came out this past weekend in
droves
hall of famer allen fanica joins the
show ben lines in for rich on the rich
eisen show allen joins us on behalf of
the steps towards zero campaign which is
inspiring those with epilepsy to educate
themselves about the steps they can take
today to get closer to zero seizures
the optimal treatment goal for people
with epilepsy talk to me a little bit
about your own experience with epilepsy
this campaign and how you almost didn't
get a chance to play football and now
here you are hall of famer that's
incredible
yeah you know so i was diagnosed when i
was 15 with epilepsy and uh you know
became a challenge uh early on and uh
you know my doctor told me that i could
continue to play football and uh i was
very fortunate uh just to have a great
support system around me and uh helped
uh help nurture me and help to
uh uh to get me going on my on the right
path uh to treatment and and health uh
that i was able to overcome it and to
continue playing uh sports in general in
high school especially football and uh
you know eventually came to a point
where i could where i could own it and
kind of manage it on my own and know my
body and uh just to
keep moving forward and i was very
fortunate to keep going and not have
anything happen during uh during
football activities um but it's just uh
you know one of those things that i've
overcome and i try to share my story
it's amazing story alan because even
after football you continue to push
yourself i read that in 2014 you ran a
marathon uh now you're continuing to do
work uh to educate those with epilepsy
as part of this steps towards zero
campaign so how has life how have you
settled into life after football
um you know i've done a little bit of
this and a little bit of that uh
currently i'm the head football coach at
uh
cox high school uh here in virginia
beach virginia where my family and i
live so uh that that's been keeping me
busy this is my first year but i've been
helping with the team for the last
couple of years and uh the head coach
stepped down so i stepped up and took it
so i'm really excited about that right
now and um you know just always looking
to uh to do things and keep busy and um
you know this uh steps towards zero
programs stepped up and i i jumped right
in
hall of famer allen fanica joins the
show as a football coach now do you ever
know tick tock in the locker room policy
how are you connecting with this next
generation of football kids
we we have a dark policy 24 hours before
a game there's zero zero anything
everybody goes dark
it's such a different aspect of the game
now than when you grew up playing or
when we grew up watching the idea of
social media and instagram and all these
things for ways players can connect now
is that something you notice just with
the kids that you're getting to work
with now as a coach
i definitely i mean that's that's how we
have to communicate with them uh you
know we have an app to to chat with them
and uh talk to them uh so it's just so
it's so different you gotta uh
there's a fine line between uh coming
down to them but also bringing them up
to you
and your standards and and
you know not everything we learned as
kids is lost so we have to bring them up
a little bit on that level
alan over the weekend uh out in canton
ohio one thing was apparent this is
definitely the greatest class in the
history of football when it comes to
hall of fame hair busts you had some
legendary hair busts going jimmy johnson
troy palamalu which of the bus hairdos
did you like the most up close
uh i think droids was pretty good i
think i i would imagine he was trying
probably trying to push them for a
little bit longer
and they probably hit a limit that it
wasn't going to fit on the on the mantle
in the hall anymore
what's that feeling like to see your bus
there amongst all the legends that you
grew up watching grew up competing
against and now to forever be a part of
that group what was that moment like
when you had your bus revealed
yeah um you know i was telling people
you know people are asking what i'm
doing there's some functions that i have
to go to by myself without the family
you know about halfway through the
weekend i stopped saying i'm uh i was in
the room with those guys and i started
saying i am one of those guys
um
so uh it's pretty surreal uh family and
i went in afterwards after was up uh in
his place in the hall to go see it and
to uh you know just kind of pan and walk
around and then all of a sudden you get
to yours um
you know i i keep saying speechless and
it's cliche and it you know it doesn't
give you guys much to work with but but
truly the whole entire experience if i
could craft the the most poignant
and best paragraph ever written
ever i don't think it would do it
justice for for how special
a moment in a week that it was for
myself and my family
compare the nerves the night before
super bowl to those
right before you get on that stage to
make that hall of fame speech
you know um
super bowl was ready to go
um kind of it's very similar actually
very similar for me uh you know you kind
of get to a point where you're nervous
uh going into the speech for me
and then i was like screw it i got this
and literally i i had my air pods with
me and i went in the back and they were
like i need you to sit down here and i
was like i got 20 minutes i'm not
sitting down for 20 minutes i'm going to
be over there you guys come find me and
i made a little playlist and had it on
and i was back there rocking out just
like it was pregame
and getting ready to go out there and uh
so it's very similar actually
nine time pro bowlers super bowl
champion and hall of famer allen fanica
joining the show want to leave you with
this we hear
lots of stories over the years of all
the great gifts that lineman received
from running backs and quarterbacks who
hooked you up the best over the years
oh man uh i got i've gotten suits and
uh tvs and um
oh man watches um you know the very very
cool stuff you know probably the coolest
would have been uh cordell gave us uh
cordell stewart gave us a plasma tv back
when plasma tvs were like you know very
far and few and uh all of a sudden we
got this and flat screens were all
everything was new uh and he gave us a
plasma tv and uh it was very cool uh and
very very new you know i still had the
box tv in the house so uh that was
pretty cool and special at the time
it sounds like being a hall of famer
playing lineman in the nfl is like
winning the showcase showdown on the
price is right right cj
i would you wouldn't know anything i
wouldn't know anything about anything
yeah alan congratulations on the uh the
honor you're a part of the football hall
of fame forever and we appreciate all
the work you're doing with the steps
towards xero campaign thanks so much for
checking in
appreciate it guys thank you
hall of famer alan fanica joining the
show and for more information on the
steps towards xero campaign just go to
steps towards xero.com
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here